the shoulder joint is a highly mobile
ball and socket joint made up of three
bones the humerus or upper arm the
clavicle or collarbone and the scapula
or shoulder blade
the humeral head is the ball-like
structure at the top of the humerus
the clavicle runs between the breastbone
and the top of the scapula
the scapula is a flat triangle-shaped
bone that forms the back and top of the
shoulder
the glenoid cavity or socket is a
shallow depression in the part of the
scapula closest to the arm
the ball of the humeral head fits into
this socket
articular cartilage is a tissue that
covers the humeral head and lines the
glenoid cavity
it allows the joint to Glide smoothly
four muscles start at the scapula and
run toward the shoulder joint these
muscles are attached to the humerus with
tendons which are strong cords of tissue
that connect muscles to bone
these tendons form the rotator cuff
which is a capsule that supports the
bones of the shoulder joint and holds
the humeral head within the glenoid
cavity
the rotator cuff gives the shoulder
joint stability keeping the ball and
socket in proper position
the rotator cuff also gives the shoulder
joint its wide range of motion
sometimes the shoulder joint can become
severely damaged from disease or injury
for example arthritis can erode the
articular cartilage in the joint causing
pain and less Mobility
injuries to the rotator cuff such as a
tear can also cause pain and decrease
shoulder joint Mobility
over time a shoulder with a damaged
rotator cuff May develop cuff tear
arthropathy a condition where the
shoulder joint develops arthritis due to
abnormal motion and instability from the
tear
severe disease or injury of the shoulder
joint may need to be treated with a
joint replacement
a standard shoulder replacement uses
manufactured materials to create a new
ball for the head of the humerus and a
new socket for the scapula
however when disease or injury of the
shoulder joint is Complicated by a
severely weakened or injured rotator
cuff a reverse shoulder replacement may
be necessary
a reverse shoulder replacement allows
the deltoid muscle in the arm to take
over movement of the shoulder joint from
the weakened injured rotator cuff
in this repair the position of the ball
and socket are reversed
the socket implant is attached to the
top of the humerus where the ball or
head used to be
and the ball implant is attached to the
scapula where the socket used to be
in a reverse shoulder replacement the
procedure will begin with an incision
over the shoulder joint
the surgeon will separate the head of
the humerus from the shoulder joint and
remove it
the humerus will be hollowed out in
preparation for placement of the socket
implant
next the inside of the glenoid cavity
will be reshaped to prepare it for
placement of the ball implant
a metal base will be attached to the
scapula with screws
the ball will be screwed onto the metal
base
the socket implant is on a metal stem it
will be inserted into the humerus
finally the surgeon will put the new
joint together by inserting the ball
implant into the socket implant
at the end of the procedure the incision
will be closed with stitches and Staples